we could not be more pleased to have
sitting here on our set one of the stars
of the new film coming out this Friday
just getting started starring along with
Tommy Lee Jones and Rene Russo in a
movie written and directed by one of the
greatest sports movie writers and
directors for sure of all time and Ron
Shelton we are thrilled to have the
Academy Award winner Morgan Freeman
right here good to see you sir good to
see you sir not really
yeah I know you got your double mics I
know that's just - just better be safe
than sorry and I okay well it's good to
see you here thank you for thank you for
for being here if I had to ask you what
your favorite sport is what is your
favorite sport Morgan Freeman golf yes
the one I play so okay
yeah so what what what game what is your
game what is the Morgan Freeman golf
game what what is it like ah it's like a
26 handicap it's what it's like okay but
it's something that I know nobody's ever
gonna perfect it is some of the most
frustrating moments I've ever had is
with a little higher I equate it to life
mm-hmm like you're never going to
perfect life just never going to you
keep trying to get better
hmm and that's what we do with golf you
just keep trying to get better in the
Tigers back and still trying to get
better and you know let's talk about
tiger a little bit then uh do you think
that he will regain form now we saw we
just saw over the weekend with the
Heroes World Challenge do you think he's
gonna game the old tiger yes I do
I think now the first requirement is
will so he has that the second
requirement is will meaning he thinks he
will so he will and the third
requirement is just plain old know-how
which he has a bucket full of yes he
does he does and how do you think he
looked this past weekend oh I was I was
so pleased
just the fact that he could swing hit
that ball that far and not wins right
no I he'll get the putting down yeah
that's just he just got back so I know I
know but but he already heard that uh
you know my could Patriot Chris over
there were saying that the the odds of
him what they go from what to what for
the man yes a couple months ago he was a
hundred to one shot to win the Masters
now he's twenty to one
haha yeah see another week two more two
more yeah I think it'll be down to
probably even yeah you know yeah as a
favorite they'll be the favorite by the
time the tank a pro to put the jacket on
have you ever met Tiger yeah remember
met him uh-huh
we just haven't moved in Sam sir hey Jim
you know Tiger hasn't been in films up
by the who knew if you were be it some
sort of tournament or golf club I've
been at tournaments I've been in a few
programs just he wasn't in any of them
he wasn't in anything no I played with
Justin Rose in China no well that Ernie
ELLs and once upon a time you know okay
what's your favorite course that you've
ever played it's hard to tell you yeah I
I got so deep into this stuff that I
built a simulator what do you mean I
mean I have a golf simulator at home at
home yeah okay so um so which one do you
like to put on your symbol beach Pebble
Beach
yeah you put one in the water on your
side I have put a lot of water right
yeah Morgan Freeman here on the Rich
Eisen show just getting started again in
theaters near you we'll get to that
shortly
are you an NFL fan of any so I'm an NFL
fan
yes okay yeah all right if I just get I
got frightened like everybody else
interesting well you know it's it's a
dangerous game mm-hmm and we only
recently finding out how dangerous hmm
so I select my girlfriend said we were
sitting down watching and she says I
hate that I like this so much so what
she said so is there any team that you
follow when you do find the time yeah
pretty much followed the Cowboys okay uh
but I'm also a fan of the Falcons and
the Saints southern okay she's right
around that if your boys run around
Mississippi yeah and you follow
Mississippi players into the NFL yes yes
okay no we got that Prescott with it
with the Dallas Cowboys yeah that's
right man yeah and we got Robert Kennedy
she yes with the card right Ole Miss he
was just drafted by the Cardinals a
couple years ago and Favre do you fine I
guess I guess Favre is mr. Mississippi
yeah so long ago the right he's now he
just selling stuff that is true you're
not wrong on that front so let's talk
about this film just getting started
it's you and Tommy Lee Jones and Rene
Russo with Ron Shelton who I mean Bull
Durham is an all-time great yeah and
well it's almost a character in the
movie that's he is he's been here before
and we just love chat with him former
ballplayer himself what what spoke to
you about doing this film just getting
started
Morgan I'm drawn now to comedy is a nice
change from all this gravitas stuff and
Tommy Lee Jones has been one of my idols
for a long time and I've known Renee
since about 1995 we were in the same
movie picture called outbreak sure so
and there's not much more you need
except Paige
you know and this movie was exactly
something like that exactly okay if I
had to give you a choice of Bull Durham
or tin cup or white men can't jump did
you which one would you choose from the
Ron Shelton whoever they like Bull
Durham that would be my first choice
what would you like about bull durham uh
Tim Robin okay
that's which gets us to Shawshank
Redemption ask the poll question of
Morgan Freeman that we asked here all
day your honor what's your favorite
Morgan Freeman movie what's my favorite
Morgan Freeman Freeman movie give him a
choice in Shawshank Redemption seven
Unforgiven Driving Miss Daisy Million
Dollar Baby
yeah what's your favorite those oh not
one you got to pick one
I got a pick one got a pick one life's
about making decisions
Morgan Driving Miss Daisy why do you
choose that one so far away from me is
that right yeah yeah I I don't I I seed
that character when I look at the movie
mm-hmm everything else I just see me you
know I'm saying huh you say you became
someone else
well III wait a minute okay bit of a
caveat here okay because Clint Eastwood
being one of my favorite directors and
acting partners me and Dollar Baby was
pretty good why me you won the Oscar for
that one for Million Dollar Baby what is
right that is true although Unforgiven
to me I've been talking about the last
two hours that's a perfect movie Morgan
I mean it I mean from beginning to end
what was it like working with Gene
Hackman in that film gene is I don't
know I you know actors they're good
actors are just very interesting people
to be onstage with and and jeans one of
them masks
he's so believable where a scene in
Unforgiven where he had me tied to the
bars in the jail and he was beating me
and questioning me and he came up in one
scene in whispered in my ear I'm gonna
ask you some questions same questions
that I ask whoever that was and if your
answers don't match up I'm gonna hurt
you
I believed him
because I think he said it not just a
little bit no I'm not gonna hurt you not
just not a little bit you know I first
foot second you thought maybe he's
actually going to do that hmm
I just loved that movie what'd you do I
twist one of my favorite people you know
I mean workwise but in terms of you know
the sports world is well I don't know
why it is but in the sports world of the
sports fans where the pop culture worlds
collide sports and movies anytime the
the Shawshank Redemption is mentioned
though it feels like there's a there's
an emotional tug that you hear from
mostly mostly guys actually watching
this film I'm wondering what what do you
think made that movie so special based
on you
I hate or tell you about it yeah it's a
love story between two men
it is probably one of the few that gets
away with it there are no women in this
movie except the ex-wife after that it's
just men and those two bond so closely
we never forget about him
everybody wonders what happened to them
what did they do
yeah once he caught up with them down
and they what's a nail what what did
they do after that wasn't there a sequel
well what do you think what do I think
this is yes probably
started some kind of business what are
you gonna do they went into business
together
you open a hotel or something a little
yeah a little boutique hotel or
restaurant o at the time say what the
nails was not on the map boating
restoration business perhaps ah that
takes a lot of work okay
now I don't know okay how many people
ask you to do their outgoing message on
their cell phone for them Morgan how
many people ask you that yet that many
come on now I don't feel well I mean
there are a few I mean that but you know
would you but come on now
what do you mean he is restaurant you
know Hotel Restaurant up in Carmel Clint
Eastwood's yeah it says you know so we
have this answering on the system on the
phone we do we do record for me yeah you
did it yeah I miss teal Ronnie okay no
kidding no kidding when you call up his
place right now and you hear Morgan
Freeman's voice call him you want a call
right now del Teufel do that in the
meantime if it's not my voice don't hold
it against me well we're gonna find this
out give it a call right now with Morgan
Freeman on on the Rich Eisen show and
before before I let you go Tommy Lee
Jones what was it like working with him
it was terrific
I had before I've admired him for so
long and so much and you're working with
people like that it's not work at all
you know it's playing great just play
acting and I do mean player brain good
so we had so much fun right Joe
Pantoliano isn't it as well Joey oh yeah
Joey panting ah yeah he's Joey pants who
is in George Bhalla Graham beckel they
were they were my flunky yes your your
flunkies again when you're playing the
manager of the Villa Capri with a
mysterious past
what's with the original title of the
movie a right now it's now you're just
getting started yeah right here did you
find it Mike or you don't have it give
it a call mission ranch restaurant okay
give it a call
here we go Morgan Freeman here on the
Rich Eisen show this is the outgoing
message I'm curious now here we go let's
hear it doesn't open until five o'clock
so we should get a voicemail here let's
here we go mr. Oz restaurant oh oh I'm
sorry wrong number wrong what did you
want to say hello to thank you do you
still have Morgan Freeman's voice on
your outgoing message there did you hang
up one last thing I wanted to ask you
forever
uh no no go ahead ask okay it's all
right I don't mind go ahead easy reader
on the electric company yeah III have no
question now just no question the fact
that I get to look at easy reader and
say thank you for helping me learn how
to read and teach me that that readin
was great I'm serious I'm telling you it
was the greatest really yeah working on
the electric company with you and Marita
Moreno and watching that as it yeah we
started out with reader and Bill Cosby
and how many years did you do that five
years nineteen seventy one seventy six
five years terrified me what do you mean
terrifying well you get to be a profile
account television or children's
television yes or just daytime TV every
day every day every day you get
identified with that and I really was
afraid of becoming typecast not typecast
hmm cast flat out like being there if
that show had kept going I might still
be this imagine imagine my reading
comprehension today without the Morgan
okay but I I profess confess yes that we
didn't teach any
comprehension okay merely word
recognition yeah because the English
were a little upset with the show
because well I took it to the next level
thanks for being here I really
appreciate it pleasure to talk with you
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience